thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies alternating current is kind
of wild if you think about it
electric charge drifting back and forth
all because a power source is flipping
back and forth
even weirder some circuit components can
be ahead or behind that drift
if there's a capacitor and an inductor
in there the cycles would look like this
it's bonkers
but what if i told you there's a better
way
what if we pretended those arrows are
rotating instead
[Music]
that might sound crazy but after all
this is the science asylum
then again it's not actually that big of
a leap with the exception of solar
panels all large scale energy generators
use rotation
there's either a spinning coil or a
spinning magnet depending on the design
we might as well work with the theory
the same way
when we have the arrows rotating like
this they're called phasers
phasers on full power captain no no not
not those kind of phasers but you said
yeah phasers not phasers
phaser is short for phase vector man i
was really excited
all right i should probably be starting
this from the beginning anyway
there are two major categories for
electricity
direct current or dc which is where
charge drifts steadily forward
and alternating current or ac which is
where charge drifts back and forth
each of those currents is a response to
a voltage
direct voltage causes direct current
that's the kind you get from things like
batteries
batteries are simple easy to understand
and portable but they're terribly
inefficient so they're expensive
alternating voltage causes alternating
current that's the kind you get from the
wall sockets in your house
this type of current is a little more
difficult to understand and a lot more
dangerous but it's more energy efficient
over long distances
so it's what we use in our power grid
it's the topic of today's video so let's
get into it
in the u.s the typical household voltage
alternates gradually between plus or
minus 170 volts
it does this at a frequency of 60 hertz
that's 60 times per second
fast fast
obviously this animation has been slowed
down so you can see what's actually
happening
wait 170 volts i thought the us was 120
volts oh that's the rms value not the
max value rms value yeah it's a kind of
average
if you have a wave like this what we'd
typically call a mean average isn't very
useful
for every positive value there's an
equal but opposite negative value the
mean average would be zero every time
but if we take a square of the wave
first then you only have positive values
we then take a mean average of that new
wave
a square root brings the units back down
to volts
what we arrive at is a root of the mean
of the squares
the root mean square or rms value
you lose information when you take
averages so you have to be kind of
careful with these
but the rms value is very popular
so popular in fact that they're the
standard for quoting numbers in ac
electronics
if you see a number like 120 volts
without any qualifiers it's an rms value
easiest way to get from that to a max
value is to multiply by root two that's
where i'm getting 170 volts
that 170 volts is what matters today
we could imagine this arrow drawing out
a wave on a moving piece of paper
alternating voltage is governed by wave
mechanics
that doesn't look so bad yeah but that's
because we're only looking at one arrow
the voltage source isn't the only arrow
though
each circuit component gets its own
arrow each circuit component draws its
own wave
i don't know about you but that looks a
little overwhelming to me
the waves aren't even in phase with each
other each of those circuit components
is responding to the voltage differently
for resistors that response looks like
this
ohm's law
the unit for resistance is ohms
get it it's an omega
it's a pun and i love it
for capacitors the response looks like
this the unit is fair ads named after
michael faraday of faraday's law fame
inductors respond to voltage like this
the unit is henry's or hanks as i like
to say
ridiculous
remember electric current is just the
response
voltage is the cause in a wave diagram
like this the capacitor and inductor are
messing everything up
they don't respond to the voltage source
they respond to the changes in the
voltage source
that puts them either ahead or behind
the rest of the circuit which can be
kind of challenging to see in a wave
diagram
that's where phasers come in
yeah phasors on metaphorical power
captain fire it will
along the horizontal we have a number
line a single axis
an alternating voltage is continuously
changing length along that axis
but say we imagined a second axis
a vertical axis
an imaginary axis
well we'd have something called the
complex plane one real axis and one for
pretend
believe it or not adding this pretend
axis makes things way easier because of
euler's formula
if all you have is a real axis your wave
might be written as a cosine
but adding an imaginary axis gives us an
imaginary sine term
euler's formula tells us this whole
thing is just an exponential which is a
lot easier to work with
the exponent is the angle around the
circle you start at zero the positive
real axis
as the angle grows the arrow rotates
counterclockwise
the real and imaginary pieces change but
the total length of the arrow is always
the same
oliver heavyside pioneered the use of
this math in electric circuits
the man never gets the credit he
deserves
good old ollie saw euler's formula and
was like oh yes
oh yes
if the real axis is in volts then the
length of this arrow is the max voltage
remember that's 170 volts for household
outlets in the us
no matter what this arrow is 170 volts
long
what changes is the projection of that
arrow onto the real axis
that projection changes over time
because of the arrow's angle
angles in this diagram are called phases
which is just leftover language from
that earlier wave diagram
since this arrow acts like a vector and
the angles are called phases we call
this arrow a phase vector or phaser for
short
it's a very descriptive name and it
sounds wicked cool i approve 100
so what happens when you have multiple
arrows math magic
if all you have are resistors in your
circuit then it's not all that
interesting the arrows line up they're
in phase
inductors are 90 degrees ahead of
resistors though we say they lead by 90
degrees
that means they'll shift the arrows out
of phase
the source voltage has to be split
between the two different components
but if you look at the electric current
you'll see it's only listening to the
resistor
that means the voltage source and the
current are out of phase
it pulled them out of phase by a very
specific angle
this angle
it's called the circuit phase angle and
it can be found with some simple trig
that angle doesn't change over time
either
all the arrows rotate together
if you want to figure out the real
voltages at any given time just pause
measure the angles and find the
projections
after that adding in a capacitor is
pretty straightforward
capacitors lag behind so they pull the
overall voltage back a little
it has to be split between three
different components now
all you need is pythagorean theorem to
relate them all to each other
the real values at any given moment are
just the projections onto the horizontal
axis
cool i know right i love phasers so much
alternating current looks like this
electric charge drifting back and forth
on an oscilloscope screen you might see
something like this
multiple waves with some ahead and some
behind
but the phasor diagram is much easier to
use
just a few arrows rotating around as a
set
here are all three together so you can
see them in sync
when the resistor arrow is horizontal
the current is moving as quickly as
possible and its wave on the screen is
at maximum
when the resistor arrow is vertical the
current is momentarily stopped and its
wave on the screen is at zero
a similar thing happens for the inductor
and for the capacitor
over and over and over again
at least until the power goes out
which totally sucks am i right you know
what else sucks business is tracking
your every move
today's sponsor surfshark can help with
that
surfshark is a vpn or virtual private
network which adds an extra level of
encryption to your internet experience
if you're like me you use some kind of
incognito or private mode in your
browser
but that only prevents your device from
keeping a record of what you're doing
and anyone else living in your home
your isp can still keep records of all
your traffic and the websites you visit
can still track what you do at least
while they're still open
and they can always see your ip address
which means they always know where you
are
surfshark can mask your ip address
thereby hiding your location
they even have their own bare bones
search engine that provides a real
incognito mode
surfshark doesn't track you either they
have a zero log guarantee
if you're interested go to the link in
the description below and enter promo
code asylum
you'll get 83 off and three extra months
for free which is a good deal it'll also
let surf shark know you heard about them
for me which helps out the channel
so what do you think how cool are phaser
diagrams pretty awesome right let us
know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like dhruv
singhal who's pledging support at our
asylum orderly level don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy
several of you asked why dark energy
wasn't in my pie chart
simple my pie chart was specifically
about the proportions of matter
dark energy is not matter
i'll do an episode about dark energy at
some point but i need to do a follow-up
dark matter video first
anyway thanks for watching